welcome to the 22nd ever episode
of the iced coffee hour of the iced
coffee hour we have made so far
seven thousand three hundred thirty
three dollars
yeah so welcome back to the podcast
that was good you know people call uh
you las vegas graham
yeah and they call you you kind of look
alike and we got this andre
yeah in las vegas but now you're coming
here yeah exactly
right so now we got two las vegas grams
i know
one of them is an imposter the the nice
one and the evil one
which one's which you're definitely the
evil one
anyway so andre you have a really cool
story you started off with
magic yes then you got into personal
finance and you started making
youtube videos on personal finance with
some really incredible editing
and you incorporate magic into your
videos and you're quickly approaching a
million subscribers
not crazy a million a million
and you've been growing really really
fast too yeah it's crazy fast get me to
a million please
everyone subscribe to andre yeah stop
what you're doing right now and
subscribe to andre thank you
yeah i'll push you over a million thank
you yeah and then you bought some
pokemon card packs
do you want to see it really i do all
right so welcome you are one of the
most highly requested guests that people
want on the podcast really
yes wow here i am so thank you so much
for coming on
of course yeah the most anticlimactic
guest ever hi no this is going to be a
great episode before
because before we even started filming
you wanted to show us your pokemon cards
i'm like no no i don't want to see i
don't want you
right i want to wait uh until we start
filming so
why don't we introduce you really quick
sure so i don't know how you want it
like i'm just going to freestyle it here
but you started in magic yeah and you
were what is it what do you call it the
cardistry right yeah so it's really
interesting do you want to tell you that
story
yes i do actually two people that care
yeah so there's a
so in magic which is basically what
you're doing you're doing card tricks to
fool people to entertain people right
that's the david copperfields the chris
angels the david blaines but within
magic there was a rift there was a
separation of people who had two
different mindsets
and there was an art form emerged that
was called flourishing right
flourishing was basically like if i had
a deck of cards i could show you but
it's like when you a magician fans a
deck of cards and i'm like pick a card
right the flourish is the deck of cards
that was fanned or like the spring you
know the little
that people do that's called a flourish
so a flourish is when you do an
action to accentuate a bigger intent so
in the sense
the intent is for you to pick a card but
the action is like really pretty
flourishy thing like he twirled his
hat with a flourish right so a bunch of
guys got together and they were like
what if we took out all the flourishes
for magic and just did that
like there was no larger intent there's
no card tricks i just want to do cool
like flippy stuff with cards
and out of that came this art form
called cardistry
so i was kind of around since the
beginning of it which was like in 2002
and i've been around since then which
was crazy and yeah we just
took a bunch of these flourishes and
made it into an art form and
uh yeah that's the story of cardistry it
looks way cooler when you actually see
what it looks like i've seen some of
these guys they do the flips where they
take it from one hand they flip it up
and they do the curl and they you see
you're able to do that yes the overhead
spring
wow do you know magic as well i do yeah
i started off with magic which was crazy
because my parents do gymnastics like
they're cirque du soleil acrobats
so i'm a circus kid like i traveled the
world with my parents
we traveled to like germany switzerland
belgium holland like all over europe and
then
my parents were like well we have a kid
let's settle down because he needs to go
to school
so my dad got called to cirque du soleil
here in vegas
to go and perform and yeah we settled
down here in vegas i started going to
school
and i always saw my parents growing up
like do this crazy stuff with their
bodies like they were manipulating doing
essentially flourishes but with their
bodies right
and so i was doing gymnastics at the
time too but i hated it because like
it's
so exhausting it like it hurts right
and so i'm like i don't want to do this
stuff forever but i
i love the fact that my parents perform
in shows and that's why i grew up around
like literally until the age of 12 i
thought every single person in the world
was a gymnast i was like hey what does
your dad do
and they're like my dad's a cop and i'm
like what do you mean
he's not a clown well is he like a is he
like is he right
camels elephants no no he's a cop wow
there's people that do things more than
the circus like literally when i was 12.
so that kind of led me down this path of
exploring this visual art art form and i
got my dad took me to a magic shop and i
was like nine years old
and i saw this card trick and it blew me
away and i was like whatever this
feeling i got
i was like i have to recreate it for
other people it's like this it's
indescribable what was the card trick ah
the card trick was just a simple pick a
card trick it wasn't anything fancy it
was called the invisible deck
okay it's basically when you're like hey
name a card
and then you name a card i take out the
deck i sho i sand it through and the
card you named
is in reverse like it's face up how do
they do that yeah how do you do that you
want to know do you reveal the trick
the fans want to know i actually do
reveal tricks but only if i know that
you would
practice it and like recreate that
feeling for other people i don't reveal
things just for the sake of like your
curiosity if you told me
how to do this i would 100 do it for
people i love doing magic
i love it yeah all right i'll show jack
he's gonna put it in his tinder profile
pick a card any card yeah yeah exactly
especially with his las vegas address
yeah so saw that card trick was blown
away
and i was like i gotta do this so i
started doing magic and that led me to
make videos of of of my magic and
i discovered cardistry later on online
forums back in you know before social
media
and then i started to do filmmaking and
i picked up a camera and i was like i
gotta make remember those skateboarding
videos
like they used to be a huge thing and
they were like doing that
baker bootleg yeah i think i used to buy
those vhs sets yeah
yes seriously and i used to put them in
watch them and then go out and
skateboard
so cardistry was going through that
phase of like
evolution if you want to call it that
and so it was interesting because as my
cardistry improved my cinematography had
to get better so i was like how do i
showcase what i can do even cooler
and so my magic and my cardistry would
improve than my video and then it was
like this little
you know game of cat and mouse back and
forth until i got a job
at a starter up like a starter company a
startup and uh
yeah we were basically teaching people
how to do magic and card tricks online
and eventually we got to work on movies
like now you see me
and uh just all over sorts of like cool
shows and
it was awesome it was a cool experience
that taught me a lot and
yeah that's the story but then how did
you make the shift
to personal finance investing yeah my
parents really sucked with money
so um they were immigrants when they
came here like they didn't know what a
credit card was
where they immigrants from uh from
russia so we were from russia and when
we came here
it was like they just bought so much
crap like on credit
in russia credit gets you yes
graham's like i'm really proud of that
one
sorry guys but yeah so my parents were
just terrible with money
and i was like i just saw them growing
up fighting about it all the time
so bad to the point where there were
months that i
thought that we would be living on the
streets because they couldn't come up
with the bills you know
they couldn't come up to pay so i was
like i never want to have this feeling
again
in my life and i was obsessed from that
moment on since i was like 9 or
10 to worry about money and how to make
more of it and i was
chasing it and i didn't get anywhere but
through that concept i just kind of
learned about the fire community
i think we had the same like upbringing
to where we
followed like the same people growing up
we watched the same youtubers
we watched simple pickup right vitalizy
tv
all of those guys good prank channels
man so great yeah but i feel like we
grew up in that same
era when those little niche communities
were just like these little secret
pockets of the internet
we would have these like weird people
that are obsessed about these weird
things
and finance was one of them and i was
always obsessed about it but in my
community
in magic i didn't know how to relate
with people because entertainers are
horrible with money
like notoriously bad i'm sure you've
heard stories because they don't they
get so much of it so
fast they don't know how to manage it
right you hear stories all the time like
mike tyson being broke and making
hundreds of millions
yeah right but those are some of the
best what about for the average person
who's doing this how much money do they
make
i mean they make a little bit above
average right they'll make 50 60k
maybe 70k maybe 100k if you're like a
really good performer and you have a
solo act
but most of them are immigrants and they
have no concept of what a roth ira is
you know or like what
a 401k is or what credit cards are how
they're supposed to work
and so they just spend it as they get it
and
that's how it works so
i like the effort though a plus
he strikes so hard i love it
you gotta keep it in all right no we're
not gonna oh
cut that out cut that out
um hold on collect ourselves here so
when did you make your first
gonna collect yourself here i'm sorry
all right all right let's go
so when did you make your first youtube
video 2019 in january okay
who inspired you to make youtube videos
actually was my friend peter mckinnon
yeah okay i didn't find you
until march or april of that year 2019
and at that time i remember you had like
300 000 subs
and one of the first videos i saw of
yours was that apple one apple credit
card
wow and that was one of the first few
videos that kind of blew up for you like
really big
you got sued by apple supposedly right
yeah oh that was golden time that was
such
that was right that's when i discovered
your channel that's when i used to see
kevin too and i was like who's this
random dude
and i see this guy all the time and at
the time i was like oh we got the same
lamp in the background that's kind of
interesting
uh that's kind of cool so that was by
chance that was totally by
i didn't know who you were until march
and we had the same haircut
kind of by chance yes the same style
yeah kind of by chance yes
but you know what it's just like i
thought about that really deep and i was
like how is it that we have so many
coincidences right
and i was like but of course we would
exist in this space where it's so public
of course two like-minded people would
find themselves at the same place
at the same time because where else
would we right
i bet you people like this exist all the
time in
separate industries but they're not as
public as ours that's true right yeah
so the fact that we found each other and
we're like twins from a different
upbringing is like
it kind of makes sense yeah that's funny
because there is a lot of physical
resemblance
like it's weird i've never noticed it
yeah until now you guys part your hair
the other way
yes this way and then they're like oh
graham stuff and you're like i was like
yeah
change the evil twins mine doesn't go
the other way mine automatically goes
this way
but yeah there's a lot of similarities
like i remember seeing your videos for
the first time
and noticing that lamp i think one of my
first comments is hey nice lamp
yeah i bet and you were like ugh that
stupid idiot stole my lamp idea
and my and my look we look the same the
look it's it's it's it's well since
i'm older i would say i'm the og you're
30.
i'm 31. 31. 30. yes you got me you got
me by a year
did you start out making finance content
on youtube
i did but i mixed it with magic you had
that idea since the beginning
yes oh man i have i could talk to you
for hours about like the theory of
youtube and how to like succeed on it
because i like i i went into the
psychology of it so deep because part of
what magicians do is they study what's
called subtleties
and we study everything from things that
you would never think about just to
recreate
five seconds of your life to make it
seem like happenstance and they're like
there's no way this dude spent
24 hours preparing for five seconds of
my life it's like no that's exactly what
i did
i prepared 24 hours just to make five
seconds of your life like mind blowing
and that's how far we go wow yeah i
don't know what point i was trying to
make with that
did you know for a fact that you were
going to be successful on youtube
with the background in doing production
and now obviously good at magic
no not at all so you didn't think you
were why did you start posting content
then
yeah because uh as i was in the magic
industry my friends peter mckinnon and
chris ramsay
they're other youtubers as well like
massively bigger than myself
and much more talented uh they kind of
encouraged me to do it they're like dude
you know how to do it and you always
talk to us about money we want to learn
just like go
do it and they were they kind of
inspired me to go and try it
and my whole thing was i was like who's
going to watch me like i don't have a
lamborghini i don't have money i don't
have millions of dollars like at least
you had
some street cred to your name like you
were a millionaire when you started
youtube
yeah so there's some level of confidence
like i didn't have because i'm like
dude i have like 250 000 saved and
invested that's
like peanuts in comparison when you're
looking at the people that are on the
internet
and i was like no one's going to watch
me i was like i'll give myself a year to
do youtube
and that's it and it just took off but
it made sense like six or seven months
into doing it
before then like nobody cared yeah i
felt the same way believe it or not even
though you say i have street cred
when i started making videos that was
nothing because i was up against the tai
lopez's
right and the grant cardones and even
the alex becker
right of just people were making so much
money i'm like who would want to care
what would care about what i have to say
the next guy is a little bit better yeah
no i think you've accomplished so much
at your age you were 26 and you were a
millionaire that is not normal
yeah but but see where i was selling
real estate i would see people younger
than me
right that had started these companies
and were doing so much better like i
remember one of my one of my first big
clients was casper
this is when they first of the mattress
company this is when they first
started and they were all these young
20-somethings
uh moving their office from new york to
l.a
they rented a house together there's
like five of them and they grew in this
whole like billion dollar company
and i remember saying that like why
wouldn't they just listen to those guys
right those guys are out
so i i felt the same way as you right no
matter where you are there's always
going to be someone
doing a little bit better a lot better
for sure and i think that's the
byproduct of being in la and there's
just so many people that are successful
i didn't have that problem but
i had the internet problem so like yeah
i wasn't successful in any way
but i had strengths and i have strengths
and i think that what i realized doing
youtube
is that as long as you have a voice and
you have a unique way of saying it
that no matter what industry you want to
attempt there will be space for your
voice as long as it's unique to you yeah
how you say it
i remember when i started watching your
videos uh your videos were intimidating
to me
because you put in such good editing and
i felt
there's just there's no way i could
compete with you on that level
there's no way and i think if there's
space for youtube between two videos
and your videos up against mine i can't
compete with you in terms of quality
right you spend so long on each video
it's so meticulous
your intros you had one intro the other
day that you must have spent
a few hours on the fly one yes
on like a 30 to 45 second intro it used
to
you used to take me yeah yeah but i
can't do that so mine i i try to
try to hit my three a week no what's
wonderful yeah about what you did
was uh it's interesting because we had
these same doubts probably at the same
periods of our lives
at the exact same time because for the
last six years of my life i just
like before i did youtube i doubted
myself i was like i want to do it i
really want to do it
and i never did it and then you had the
courage to do it earlier by like what
two
three years then i think you can we'll
call it late
2006. it was december two it's really
january 2017.
okay so two years yeah two years right
and that gave you
first mover advantage right so now
you're kind of known as the finance guy
and
anything that anybody else does because
our industry's so small
is like whenever there's a new up and
comer it's like well they're copying
graham
and that's because our industry is so
tiny but like how many youtubers are
there in the gaming space and yeah
in the space literally anything does
that bother you
it doesn't bother me no but i'm just
saying like because
it is so small it is so easy to make
those similarities and comparisons
between us
even though like it's fine to have
multiple people teaching finance like
like i said how many other
youtubers are there in literally any
other space that's true so many
yeah um so yeah
i don't know where i was going with this
i totally lost my train of thought i was
gonna say something good that happens a
lot you're gonna tell them this smash
the like button for the youtube
algorithm of course
smash the youtube button for the youtube
algorithm i totally got that wrong
so what kind of investing strategy do
you employ for right now
what's what's your i'm just trying to
diversify yeah i used to be just a huge
dividend investor and i still am
but i'm just trying to find other
avenues as well for like real estate and
crypto and all the other ones as well
can we talk about
the cash position can we excuse me is
that on limits
sure holding a lot of cash yeah are you
two
i am yeah but it was kevin o'leary so it
must be fine
but you're holding a lot of cash i think
you're holding more i am
yeah i am yeah what i'm saying but i
have you
i i have some like 30 of everything in
cash
okay what would you say your cash cash
it's hard to say cash
position say yes cash cash position
cash position cash position it's hard to
say
what what would you say your cash cash
cash position cash position cash
position percent
position is what would you say it is
right now i would say
it is ninety percent ninety percent
yeah but part of that it's like over a
million dollars it's over a million
dollars but part of that
why don't you invest because i've never
made this much money in my life and i'm
terrified
of making a mistake and because i don't
know how much i want to pay in taxes i
mean i have an idea obviously yeah
but the fact that like i have to pay so
much in taxes i just want to make sure
that
i get an idea about what's gonna happen
you're not gonna pay a million dollars
in taxes i know yeah
it's gonna be closer to 400 450 500
maybe yeah which is still a ton of money
i know i can invest the difference but i
don't know there's still something that
i'm holding off and i'm just like you
know what i'm going to wait
uh and see what go what about dollar
cost averaging or something really safe
i still dollar cost average every month
yeah
it's just like it's i mean it's peanuts
in comparison to what i'm making
yeah i'm still investing that's i'm
still investing five or six thousand a
month
like that's i'm still doing that you're
missing the run-up though
and i am who's to say maybe next month
it drops 20 percent
right who knows but there's all those
calculations that show you
that investing as soon as possible is
always better than holding off
really they did that study where dollar
cost averaging was beaten by lump sum
yes
66 percent of the time lump sum
investing beats dollar cost averaging
okay i think i think i read that
somewhere you have
yeah a lump sum right available to you
right the difference is when people make
one investment and that's it versus
investing consistently investing
consistently will always
win but if you have a lump sum available
right now
investing all of it at once right wins
66
i don't think i'm making that much of a
misstep just because i'm still investing
it's not like i'm sitting out and i'm
waiting to time it right
because there's a ton of studies of like
people trying to time it trying to time
the market perfectly and even if you
time it correctly
like five times in the last 50 years
you'd still lose to the person who just
consistently invested month over month
right but you but this isn't all the
money you're you're going to have you're
not gonna have
let's call it 500 grand lump summon you
can invest once and that's it
well that's kind of what you're saying
well not what you're saying but i have
to do that right now like i would just
have to invest 500 grand all at once i
did
ideally which ideally i'm a little
terrified or you take
200 000 chunks take 150 000
chunks on the first of the month for
sure 150 grams
that's arguably like also dollar cost
averaging yes but the whole point is
getting over the psychological
uh hesitation for just dumping into the
market
for sure because i think this almost
reinforces then right that
i waited this long i'm gonna keep
waiting no i don't think so i think next
year i'll definitely go hard on it
it's just my first year and i like i
don't like i better not be surprised
yeah i've never made this much money in
my life and i have no idea if next year
it's going to continue or is it going to
go down like
you know what i mean i don't know
honestly i have no idea that is really
new to this world
that is smart because graham does say
like and a lot of people say this as
well
but if you start making a bunch of money
at once or if you get like some sort of
like crazy windfall
yes the best thing to do is just
literally sit on it yeah which is
exactly what i'm getting it does
it does make sense yeah yeah that what
you're doing plus you're
you said you're 30 right like you're 30
is more than my million
so like yeah that's true i mean
objectively as far as numbers that means
70
of my money is invested right but that's
still millions of dollars that not
not 90 non-investments well i mean
percents aside when we're talking about
an objective number
we're still talking about this is true
millions on your behalf that you are
earning
less than 200 million but my tax bill is
probably okay there you go you got that
same reason yeah
taxes you know how much taxes you're
gonna pay it's not a surprise right yeah
right so literally your interest money
is actually losing more money than my
million because you have more millions
so even though the percent is more i'm
looking at percentages here yeah but i'm
not
not talking percentages of total
portfolios right now
percentages are meaningless in the
context of how much overall money we're
talking about right
no what's a percent no because 90 of
your money's not invested
30 of my money's not invested right so
that's the difference
yeah you need more money invested no
also you guys are in completely
different situations
so i would say if i was in graham
situation i would be acting more like
kim if i was in yours i would definitely
be
very very like hesitant to actually
i'm not saying that you're being a
hypocrite i would do the exact same
thing in your position
just because when you have graham's
level of wealth
your goal is then not necessarily to
risk that money as much as it is to
protect
what you have and at my level i mean
maybe you can make somewhat of the same
point but for me i guess i'm comparing
not percentages because
my million dollars that's missing let's
say seven percent per year
is let's say seventy thousand dollars
per year missing out on appreciation but
if you have three million or two million
in cash you're literally missing out on
two to three times as much so
objectively speaking numbers if we're
looking at the actual dollar figure
you're missing out on more money
yes but i'm also looking at for deals so
if i see a good real estate deal
especially moving
here to las vegas that opens up a lot of
doors
oh for sure so that's why i keep cash on
hand because when you see a good deal
same for me right we're both looking
like you're not buying real estate
i will what are you talking about soon
we want we want andre to move into the
house next to me yeah and i really want
to
yeah this is where we're spilling it
yeah because you said uh you said uh
someone who we're not going to talk
about is planning because you didn't
want to get people's hopes up oh yeah i
guess but now i guess everyone knows
spill the beans yeah yeah so um yeah so
i guess i could be
grams and is it okay to say who else
jeremy jeremy's neighbors yeah that
would be super cool
um i just don't have my two years yet
and literally everybody i'm speaking to
they're like just wait two more months
you're not going to get a prime rate
from a jumbo loan right now and i'm a
prime candidate so i might as well wait
two months why like
risk anything and why pay more yeah i
really want you as a neighbor
yeah that'd be good think about it think
about those think about all the content
all the content we can make seriously do
you want to
think we would make more content if we
were next donating yes
we're here now we came all the way here
to do a podcast with you imagine having
you back
as a regular guest imagine just being
able to walk out
what do you think of this thumbnail what
do you think of this title right stress
the work
jack and i do together cannot be done
over zoom for sure done over the phone i
just feel like we're doing such
independent work that we wouldn't
necessarily collaborate in a way that's
like
but we would do you think so we would
check in on each other a lot yeah
guaranteed yeah we could be
accountabilities yeah the only sucky
thing we would not be able to do is like
yo you want to hang
like no i'm not home what do you mean
you're not home i can see you from the
window
i'm working tonight that's probably what
would happen if
anything it would just be i'm working
that's what i'm saying is working
tonight too that's what i'm saying yeah
we were together like maybe once a month
with jeremy we'd go get some sushi and
then we would go back to our i don't
think so no
i honestly don't think so i don't know
yeah yeah but
to be fair like i i don't know like i'm
looking at vegas real estate because
let's face it you haven't lived here for
20 years right
right and i think people from california
that are coming here to vegas so by the
way the vegas market because why not
um here in las vegas uh we have low
inventory we have low interest rates
and people from california like you said
are fleeing to vegas just because it's
so much cheaper
but what looks cheap to you i'm like
it's not this is not cheap this is very
expensive right for our standards so
i'm like i'm like i don't know if i want
to buy a house like that that's brand
new that's you know it's going to build
it's going to be building
or should i buy one that's already on
the market but you're not
getting as much of a deal if you're
building especially with a luxury
builder
i disagree from the research that i've
done and from who i've talked to it
seems like in these new communities when
homes are being built you can get in at
a discount
and then prices only go up as more homes
are built because you get a lower price
for having to deal with construction
for a year right so if i could deal with
construction for a year but save
a hundred thousand dollars compared to a
home that's fully done
i'd rather do that it seems like a lot
of these new constructions after five
six years start to go
down in value versus getting in now
going up in price and then having more
time for it to go back and down and
depreciate i guess my thing is you're
kind of already paying a 30
premium for what you could already be
buying that's already on the market
and why is that is that just because las
vegas right now is really hot
just the builders understand what's
going on they understand it's low
inventory they understand people from
california are moving in
and it's just always been like that
people that are building new homes are
just right out of the gate paying a 30
premium on the same thing that's already
i haven't seen that
i looked that one day at like 13
different houses yeah
and the one that i got was objectively i
think the best price for the value
of that community yes all of summerlin
and henderson
right i looked at 13 homes between them
i don't know i've spoken to my friends
who also live in like luxury markets
about that
and they just said like if you're gonna
live in a home that let's say doesn't
even have a pool over a million dollars
it's gonna be very difficult to sell
unless you build a pool which i know you
want to pull yeah
yeah but that's still like you're gonna
pay extra and for a house in vegas for
over a million that doesn't have a pool
that is a huge premium that most houses
on the market just
i mean if you're gonna buy a million
house like you can have a massive pool a
finished backyard
like i'm just saying what looks like a
great deal from a
californians perspective from somebody
who's lived here for 20 years is like a
huge night and day difference so have
you seen a lot of appreciation of las
vegas real estate no i'm seeing
depreciation right
now every house that i'm looking at
they're just every month
not like it's not crazy depreciation but
before this to build up the real estate
prices
was there significant appreciation for a
few years or so i mean the run-up to the
low interest rates yeah i just exploded
right are we looking
at the right at the same homes because
everything that i'm saying is selling
like i
favorite home selling they're gone in a
week it is selling and that's and that's
in the 750 to i want to say the one
seven yeah over one eight i agree with
you it seems like the market there is
soft
yeah under one eight it's just like
everything is big i'm not arguing that
they're
not selling they're definitely selling
that's that's not the point but they are
definitely selling yeah but that that's
you know that still doesn't speak to the
value
that just speak to the velocity of sales
it's just i don't think has much of a
relationship well
you could be in in the perspective of
the buyer so
something could be 10 overvalued but if
to another person that's
cheap they're going to buy it they're
going to continue building yeah that's
what california people are doing here
right they're coming here and they're
like this is so cheap
and we're like no it's not you guys are
making it more expensive kind of like
what logan paul did with pokemon cards
but just watch
it's going to get way more you think so
i i'm the tip of the iceberg
seriously i think as things
progressively get worse
more and more people are going to move
and i think this whole pandemic has
caused everyone to realize they could
work from home
a lot of people are going remote and a
lot of people think you know why why do
i need to live in such an expensive city
when i could just go over here i think
that's 100 true i think what you're
not taking into account is the fact that
like i have a lot of friends here that
are like i like to call boots on the
ground
and they have like normal people jobs
and uh
what i'm seeing from them every single
one of them like
unanimously are like dude there's a
tsunami coming in vegas
we don't know when it's gonna hit but
for example here on thursday right
across the nation there's gonna be over
40 000 people laid off
vegas gets hit the hardest as well as
hawaii um
the people that are coming here which
are californians are not our clients
they're not the people that spend the
millions of dollars in the casinos
these are the average workers i mean yes
they make a fat
salary of six figures but they're not
the whales they're not that
people from china that spend all that
money yes and because of that
we are getting a massive amount of
layoffs from casinos and all across the
board
so the only saving grace that i could
argue against myself
is that maybe the luxury market
insulates
those kinds of people so like if you and
i buy a luxury home
that's 1.5 million you could argue those
people are probably
a little bit more savvy than the average
home buyer and they're probably doing it
with a safety net in mind so maybe those
home values won't collapse as hard
but i think just unanimously like people
are losing jobs we are gonna lose a lot
of money here in the real estate you
know what was interesting the realtor i
talked to when i was asking him about
just price insulation he mentioned that
from his experience this was a realtor
of like 20 something years
in las vegas mentioned that above one
and a half million dollars
a lot of those buyers he calls it buy
down
those are buyers who could afford to do
a three million four million dollar
house
they're downsizing so for them that's
cheap or that's affordable
to go with that price point right and so
those buyers are the ones where during a
downturn
he said i have no i haven't researched
it that much
those homes typically hold in value
because those are the buyers
uh and homeowners who just can wait it
out yeah and just keep it this is a
really interesting economy because
there's like
signals that make both
like sense across both directions so you
could argue i think that's 100 true
right
but then you could also make the case
that people are going to lose their jobs
and
the luxury market is almost always the
first to fall
it's almost always the first that goes
it's the luxury goods that
that fall the hardest and these luxury
homes i don't know it could go in one
way or the other they could
be insulated more just because those
people are more savvy they have more
money they could
hold through the downturn more or we
could see a massive collapse of real
estate of 20-30
in a couple months once the evictions
start to happen i don't know did you
watch my video on evictions i did
what do you think i don't think we're
gonna see a mass wave of i know you
don't think the numbers the numbers
don't add up i think the numbers go in
both way
i think literally it's the flip of a
coin right now how it's done
the national multi-family association
uh found that like 93 percent of tenants
are still paying on time across tens of
thousands of rental units
90 yeah yeah it's like 92 percent
right yeah i don't know that's not the
statistics what did you read
i don't remember but it's not what i
read yeah no national multi-family house
just saying we're getting what it was
like we're getting mixed signals from
every sorts of
media platform like everyone is telling
us a different story all i know
is that as far as the real people that
work here they are getting laid off like
crazy
and things are seen again i've seen it
with all of my friends with my parents
with my roommate
he's still out of a job he just got
permanently laid off like this is the
heart of vegas this is what operates our
properties
and if vegas is going to start sucking
for tourism
we are not going to be a you know we're
not going to be doing really well very
true and like i said it could go one way
or the other you could very well be
right and
maybe the luxury market will continue to
go up or maybe it'll stay
but i think we will at least see 10 to
20 drop and
that's not to say that i'm gonna wait
until that happens like you know what i
mean like
if a 20 drop happens i'll be okay you'll
be okay
so yeah i'm not gonna try to time it is
what i'm saying yeah
but i to me it's the toss of a coin like
i don't know which way it's gonna go i
don't think anybody knows
and it and your argument is a favor
i do agree the loss las vegas is way
more volatile yes
overall nationally real estate dropped
about 35
yeah vegas i think dropped as high as
like
80 percent for sure but also the bubble
in vegas was higher than
any other area and still if you look
back historically
vegas is not recovered to uh three
all-time highs
when you account for inflation right
like the curve was so high up that now
we're like
halfway up up the curve from where it
was in 2006. disregarding inflation
where
we're back at the same price but not
when you take that into account right so
because
we have such a interesting economy right
like in l.a yeah
you live to whoever you live next you
probably know your neighbor you probably
speak to them or like you
okay maybe you don't because you're like
i don't you're like me we don't really
have like much of a social life but
most people in california they're very
community oriented
like here in vegas it is such a
transient town the people that come here
and they work they're here for a little
bit and then they leave
there's no sense of like permanent
community and because of that
jobs there's such a high turnover rate
and that's why there's so much
volatility
it's the same for hawaii hawaii gets hit
i think either the hardest or the second
hardest after vegas
so but if you had the opportunity
to would you enter the luxury house you
know i'm really thinking about it
it's so interesting because like i said
now i have this windfall of income right
and i'm like is this going to keep going
do i buy a fancy house because the house
that i
live in right now is like 275 000
i pay 1400 well i don't pay 1400
we pay 1400 i pay 450 dollars
a month for my rent and like you know
i'm going to get that again man the
amount of money that i save is like
literally 99
now at this point so on one hand it's
hard to leave that but on the other hand
right now my success is the thing that
is crushing
my success because now i've hit this
threshold where in order to grow
i need to expand and i need to start
hiring people to help me edit
to help answer comments to help answer
emails and sponsorships
because now at this point i'm upsetting
more people than i'm like growing
because now it's like well andre how
come you're not doing patreon you're not
posting as much and it's just like
there's only one dude doing this and now
that there's thousands of people
with expectations i can't grow beyond
this point unless i start expanding and
i'm like do i
do i want to buy a fancy luxury house
because if i have this
fancy four or five thousand square foot
home maybe with a basement i can turn
that into a studio
have a live-in editor it's gonna be
awesome or do i continue just living
here really modestly
and just continue what i'm doing i'm
kind of torn i don't know what to do
that's a that's a
good conundrum to have it's a good i
mean here's here's my thought is that
once you move from here you're never
going to move back so this is your one
chance where you could spend
450 a month and save 99
yeah the other issue that i see is you
need more places to film from and i do
think you need to spice things up a
little bit i do
so i think moving into a larger house
with a live-in editor or someone to help
you
is going to really expand your business
i think a good middle ground
for you possibly might be to rent some
sort of house or
office space that you could work from so
you still stay here
but you could rent let's say a warehouse
right and just turn that into a studio
that's a full tax write-off
yeah and then hire an editor or someone
to work with you
who would stay there i thought about
that and then i waited against owning a
luxury property and i was like well what
if i buy a luxury property it's kind of
nice because now i have built-in equity
and
now i'm building equity and maybe two
years from now if things don't work out
with youtube i could still sell it
at worst maybe break even assuming
prices don't collapse so
why did you decide against that then
decide against
buying the warehouse oh because i think
i'm missing out on the upside of
potentially owning a luxury property
that could appreciate in price over the
next two years so even if youtube
doesn't work out for me
if i buy a million dollar house maybe
two years from now it'll be worth a bit
more if i sell it
at worst i could break even assuming
prices don't here's what you could do is
this man okay i got the perfect solution
for you
stay here buy a luxury house 100
business use right the deductions that
you could get from that are crazy cost
segregation analysis you could basically
take
i want to say maybe 30 of the structure
and depreciate that over the first year
you'll have to look into all the
specifics about that but take
30 to the cost of the building
depreciate it all
the first year that could be a few
hundred thousand dollars as a tax
write-off
but then the interest you pay that's a
tax write-off
property taxes right off is it an
interest-only loan you're talking about
no you get a regular 30-year mortgage on
the house
and you you deduct the interest on that
okay so if your mortgage is 6 000 a
month
35 of that is interest there there you
go what's the downside to that
no downside i mean no i i wouldn't see
it that's what i wanted to do
yes okay yeah well i'm i'm living in the
house so i can only
uh depreciate the cost so i can only
depreciate basically what i'm using
exclusively for business
but in la before i made the decision to
move
i was looking for a house that i would
be able to fix up and use
100 as an office and i looked for months
to try to find something just nothing
made sense or it was way too much work
for me to die how do you write off 100
of the house if you're not using 100 of
it for business use
what how would how do you write off 100
of the house if you're not using 100 you
don't
but in your case because you're living
here and you're buying a house for your
business that would enable you to use
that 100 for business
so my llc would own it then no you own
it okay
and there's there's plenty of ways to go
around you could you could rent it to
the uh
llc right or you could just straight up
on your own taxes
talk to the cpa i'm sure there's a lot
of creative ways to structure it with a
trust or something no you don't need to
get that creative i mean there
i just don't know the exact specifics
for your situation but
there's ways to do it okay i'll look
into it yeah yeah i'm sure you'll figure
it out first and then you'll tell me
well i did it over at uh i forgot what
it was on on uh
the duplex i forget how she had it
structured but i had the entire
garage that was like 500 square feet wow
of
my 800 square feet of living space that
was
specifically for business use and it was
okay yeah look into it
so what can do it but a lot of great tax
advantages but i'm not sure that i want
to buy a luxury home just yet like i
don't know what to do or do i buy a
normal house like this
and then pay it off in like a month or
two and now i have a property that i can
have a living editor and use exclusively
as my studio and then rent that to them
as well
i will say you're probably best off
staying here and buying a place
exclusively for business use right
that's what i figured yeah but not
necessarily a luxury one
it could be anything but i think there's
also a benefit of having a nice place to
work from oh like my backyard is so
inspiring to work like i get more done
in my backyard yeah i mean your house is
so cool like you're
first your area is amazing yeah what do
you think needs to happen in your life
for you to make that decision to
buy a piece of real estate just
that's not the politically correct way
of saying it so i won't say it uh just
just get more courage and just
i think if i have a little bit of a few
months next year in 2021 just to see how
things are going
if i'm still making like a of still a
good amount then i would probably have
more courage
but i think i'm ready at this point like
i think even if things were to collapse
even next year for me
i could still pay for the place for a
year without breaking a sweat yeah you
know what i mean like it's fine
it's just i've never done anything like
this before and it's such a huge
like lifestyle inflation move that
you can't go back you can't go back
that's been my one
lesson is is moving from that one
bedroom
one bathroom 800 did you do you saw it
right yes
yeah oh that's right okay going from
that like i was super stoked with that
place
and i for me that was all the space i
ever needed right
um when macy moved in i was like okay
it's not big enough for two people when
we're both like
home all day so then the santa monica
house was perfect
but that was a huge style like i was so
nervous for that entire month
right i always like what happens if some
something happens to the business if i'm
not able to pay okay
well worst case i could rent out the
house and then the guest house then move
back into
like i'll make it work and then after i
would say like two months i'm like
okay no this is fine right where's the
next one right so it's
amazing how quickly your mind adapts to
that and then it's like no big deal
i know but even at that point it's so
easy to be like i'm ready for my next
movie yep
you know and it's just it's so
interesting i just watched the
minimalism documentary by matt diabella
and it was so great i mean i love
minimalism financial minimalism
and it's just it's so true that you're
content at this one place in your life
but as soon as you start
trying to go beyond that boundary or you
start to compare yourself to other
people it is
so easy to be displeased with what you
have and then once you expand you're
like
cool i mean that becomes your new norm
yeah
but i will say in defense of that i was
able to do
much better work from that house it has
nothing to do
with the cost it has everything to do
with it
the tranquility and just the feel and
the warmth of the space
just mentally speaking mentally speaking
and it had nothing to do with that being
an expensive house or being i mean it
wasn't that much
the house your plate how many square
feet is this 2 000
this is bigger than the santa monica
house where i'm living wow
this is bigger i think this is a few
hundred square feet bigger than where i
have your house is what like
1800 eight times more expensive than
this one yes
and it's 1800 square feet but for me it
was the backyard
right of just posting up in the backyard
having the breeze
right there's something inspiring about
that that makes me wanna
yeah uh push myself further so it's
really interesting because a few months
maybe not a few months ago like
literally a month ago we just started i
don't know if you experienced the same
thing all of our views started dropping
yeah it's like looking at these million
dollar homes and i'm like
oh crap this month views are not doing
well
i was like yeah see i feel like if i had
a huge
responsibility like that over my head i
would be so much more stressed so on one
hand
yeah i would have more tranquility and
just that whole aspect of the mentality
but then i would also have this stress
of like
oh my god this month the numbers are
down what if they're going to keep going
down that's a good point
i waited to buy that house until all of
my investments could cover the cost of
the house
right so you could pay in cash the
entire how
cost the house right uh at the time yeah
actually i think at the time
i could have bought the house cash yeah
but even then with with the down payment
i put in the mortgage
so i think all in it's like eight grand
a month right i made sure all my other
rental properties
could cover that one right so everything
sustains itself and worst case scenario
is that it just breaks even or what you
like even worse than that i'm like okay
i'll rent out the guest house it's
another 2500
a month coming in that'll put me in the
green so like i did all these
calculations to make sure
everything would i could afford it see
without relying on youtube i don't have
those sources of income
if anything my sources of income there's
like three of them that are responsible
for i would say like 90
of my income yeah which is terrifying so
i'm trying to build
other sources of revenue that at least
i'll have a little bit more yeah so in
case one of them doesn't do well i could
at least rely on the other ones and just
right now
even though i'm making stupid money not
as stupid as yours
it's still like it's still scary
i would say your goal should be having
one million dollars invested in the
stock market
when you do that make the down payment
on a house
okay i don't know one million invested
in the market
right yeah i could do that
after taxes though i don't know
hopefully i'll still be a millionaire
yeah i think so one million invest in
the market yeah what are you three
streams of income
three streams of income yeah you said
you have three like substantial yeah
substantial ones is youtube ad revenue
uh affiliates and patreon
those are just the biggest ones for me
now you we should talk about briefly
about pokemon should be talking about
because let's bring in this let's make
it a little more fun and lighthearted
it's been getting like really immediate
yeah yeah yeah okay
let me let me ask this um so besides the
stock market then
what about other investments is that you
were going to show alternative forms of
investments i don't know if they're
investments or if they're more like
justifications for my childhood
i'm sure we all have that it's like
what is this i'll show you this oh yeah
i've never noticed all the rest of all
the ladies
oh my goodness my pokemon bring all the
nerds to the yard
wow i got this really cool card it's a
shadowless first edition
psychic energy card of all the cards you
picked you had like a one in four
shot one in five shot of picking that
card and you picked the card yeah it's
the one i wanted wow
look at this oh i remember these who
what was your name erica
erica yeah yeah her name is erica yeah i
got erica's whoa
i remember these holy crap what what is
this worth so this is a venusaur this is
basically
base shadow venusaur yeah it's not like
shadowless i don't have a single shadow
oh my god
wait can i hold it can i can i hold it
can i yeah
that one is so cool the dark charizard
yeah dark jars are i had this okay so
this is a japanese charizard
yeah wow i remember this i i like i used
to like the japanese
uh shiny cards yeah because they had a
cooler holographic i thought so too
yeah and they were more vibrant not only
that but you were guaranteed a
holographic whenever you bought a
japanese pack
that's right you remember i forgot about
that yeah
they were worth like 14 or 12 like
something ridiculous
this i remember at the card store would
be like 30 bucks yeah the cards are back
then and i like the back
of these cards yeah wow i always thought
these were cool
check this out first edition rocket one
yeah you're not delicate man it's it's
giving me anxiety i'm holding these so
carefully
look at that whoa can i see this one
yeah
they're not graded that's why i'm not
like babying them and i'm not going to
graze yeah so
yeah oh yeah i see all the scratches on
it and yeah wow
who would have thought man what's this
blastoise worth it's it's just a
regular blastoise i don't know regularly
how much is that worth i don't know
that's a good question
imagine if you stole these if it if it
was you you came to my uh
elementary school i'll tell you i told
your story to corey i was like graham
stopped collecting pokemon cards when he
got his cards stolen
yeah and corey's like but you stole
yours back
i had my cards stolen and i broke into
the
person's house and stole them back when
i was a kid i broke into my house and i
knew who it was i
stole them back oh my god it was amazing
so when'd you stop collecting when yeah
i don't remember yeah i literally don't
remember
i'm still collecting it's cool you don't
stop collecting you showed me this thing
that you got from the
the pokey mint or whatever you want to
call it right
you bought it for two thousand dollars
and it's now seven thousand yeah it's
like on
it's like on ebay for five or seven and
that's a good investment then
that's awesome dude that's so cool
whoa careful about your first edition
energy card is probably worth more than
any other card in here
if it's graded it looks like a psa 10.
it's gotta be a psa that's for sure
gosh yeah well good stuff
make sure to get b-roll on that so
should we wrap up here we're at an hour
it's still recording still we probably
have 10 minutes though that we weren't
necessarily talking i mean let's make it
more fun we talked about pretty heavy
stuff
let's talk about it what do you what do
you do for fun what do i do for fun
i have no fun i have no life no i'm
kidding
i just hang out with corey my girlfriend
yeah how long have you been corey
how long have i been how long have you
been cory
[Music]
yeah yeah we met on tinder cool yeah you
did
we did i'm trying to find love on tinder
man dude it works
it works sometimes you get people that
are just you know you're gonna be your
friends and some people are like oh
you're cool let's be more than friends
and you just never know
you know it's the digital age i guess
everyone's meeting on tinder and like
whatever other
social media network there is bumble
that's true yeah bumble bumble's the
worst girls never respond i mean i think
the other one's supposed to initiate the
conversation
but then they don't put any effort into
it they're like hey really
oh yeah no because they don't have to
put effort in no because they know the
guys will respond you know what's crazy
this must have been like four years ago
um i had a bumble profile yeah didn't
get any matches like like
i'm talking like like a match every now
and then this was obviously before
youtube
yeah oh yeah i mean this is like four
years ago whatever uh
almost no matches yeah i changed the
picture
just to see what would happen of myself
in front of a lamborghini with the doors
up
oh i kid you not overnight you know how
it showed you like like the potential
matches
it was like 50 plus no way overnight
and it got to a point on bubble i would
just swipe match match it's obviously
all about the title and thumbnail ctr
but that is your thumbnail at the very
least i'm not saying they're all like
ooh lambo because
they don't know what the car is right
but if they're scrolling it at least was
like oh what's this
right it's crazy you know graham said
something really really funny to me
he's you said when you had tinder you
know you could super like someone yes
and it has this corey super liked me
yes oh yeah nice well has this blue glow
at the bottom of your tinder card or
whatever graham edited all of his photos
to have the blue glow everyone saw that
i super like people thought
that yeah the girls would think that
graham's super like which you can only
do one every 24 hours
oh yeah drastically improved
my matches were so much that i i
physically like i couldn't keep up
with with the amount of messaging back
wow it got so overloaded
and i had to be really careful about
which profiles i swiped on because
more than likely it was going to be a
match yeah i couldn't believe it
it lasted about maybe 30 days before i
kind of noticed from tinder that they
took down my profile
oh no yeah so it worked up and to the
point it didn't and then they changed
the i guess they changed the the super
like now or so i don't i don't know did
you ever meet up with any of the people
that you matched yeah you did
did you make friends or did you date
anybody old girlfriend
for um gosh almost two years
i had no yeah yeah tinder i didn't know
that that's cool huh
good thing macy's not here
right now many years ago i prefer bumble
i think
i honestly spend more time on bumble
than i do on tinder i don't spend a ton
of time on either
yeah but i do spend more time on bumble
because i feel like it's just much
easier when they message first yeah
right you're a good looking dude you're
kind of tall you got it all stop it
right now
yeah no i mean being like five foot
seven and five foot two grant
by foot five but you guys are ripped
okay you guys are ripped
okay i'm out of shape now yeah but it's
crazy
how much street cred you get with girls
just for being tall
like be like was in jail have no job
completely broke six foot five girls are
like six foot five
that's great i don't know i think people
focus on what they don't have because i
don't view
my high at all as a perk i really don't
think about it i don't think about it
all
and i think about other things and i'm
sure it's the same way with everybody
they only really highlight the
negativity what is your downside what
would you say like your critique of
yourself is i couldn't say it publicly
oh i couldn't say it publicly why
because you know what i'll do it
until i would say three years ago maybe
about three four years ago
it took me that long to get over my
height i was i was
not self-conscious about my height until
i would say
right after high school because in high
school like it didn't matter i had i had
a good group of friends
nobody cared it didn't it didn't make a
difference then when i got out and
i want to see the real world put myself
out there there was
one moment where a friend was setting me
up on like a blind date this is like
right after uh my girlfriend of like two
years in high school broke up with me so
it was like
shattered like i had no self-confidence
my friend was like don't worry bro i'm
gonna set you up on a date with this
girl she's gonna hit it off like
and he made it seem like this perfect
thing and the girl walks in she's like
oh wow you're short
and just like but i don't i don't even
know if she meant that in like an ew
way but just says maybe just like oh hey
you're sure like something like that but
you know what you gotta do afterwards
droid me
you know what you gotta do afterwards
you gotta give her an egg like oh yeah
you're right but that's a cute shirt my
grandma owns that shirt
oh wow you're ugly no just you guys
so how did that feel like did not crush
your spirit crushed it i'm so
crushed it took me years to get over
people don't realize like one
random thing if you can like pick out
someone's insecurity with one comment
you may have no idea you might set them
off on a path to overcompensate and
become a youtube billionaire yeah
exactly i'm going to get a youtube
channel from there i can make millions
of dollars
teaching you laugh now but i think there
is truth in that i think
i don't think so i think there's truth
in in in people that
have less throughout life or like have
less confidence to work extra hard to
make up for what they feel they lack
really i think so i think that's
probably a lot of cases
you know but i wouldn't say that goes as
a general
i think that is a general rule really
and i think there are exceptions but i
think it is a general rule
i don't i don't think so i don't think
that's why you started right
i'm just saying that there is
subconsciously some some aspect of you
that
but then again that's every single
person that's every person yeah we
desire to have status to some extent to
make up for what we think we lack but
maybe there is an inequality
with people that are more self-conscious
for sure oh it's stopped recording yeah
i ran out of memory
i just want to say you know i could be
completely ignorant to it this is just
what i my initial thought
okay but something like height there's
nothing to hide
right because when you meet someone i
mean it's just right out there in the
open that's true
so it's not like it's not like your law
is right there no
i'm not everyone can see it i'm just
saying like if that's your insecurity
ever like
it is apparent you know it like not that
it's your insecurity but that
you know that is yeah i guess i think
you call me short no no i'm not saying
that
it's just it's evidence it's right there
what i'm trying to say is guys you guys
are really giving me a hard time with
this all right
what i'm trying to say is like it's
there right yeah whereas something else
this something else can eat away at you
because you know that they don't know
man it sounds like you just you you feel
like we don't need to get into it
let him lead into it i'm not gonna lead
into it but i'm just saying like
this is something that you know like you
could blame it
you could bleep it out and we'll just
talk vaguely around it really yeah we
could talk vaguely around it okay
i've got a ginormous heart no
like my biggest insecurities i'll tell
you okay so i guess
ever since i was a kid that i was i was
fat i was really fat i was really
insecure about that
um and then as i got older i was so
insecure about being fat that i would
wear a rash guard i would never be
shirtless
so then i was extremely pale and like i
would yeah so i was
really pale for all my life and i was
extremely nervous about that and this
may seem small to you but i wouldn't
take off my shirt in front of people in
a way
and then as soon as i started getting
tan because i started running
cross-country i started getting chest
hair
and now it's like a forest man like it's
crazy yeah you can't tell
yeah but like it's a forest bro
and i thought that when that happened
that would be the day that i would call
it quits you know there's the thing
what there's there's this thing called
the trimmer it's amazing
no but it's not the same bro because you
get red bumps it like obviously it's
still there
no don't go bald just just trim it i
know i do trim it but at the same time
that is probably my number one yeah
right just overall overall
ape man okay it's not a big second
second to that i would just say
asymmetrical face man
like you sound like a girl yeah no i
don't
you don't understand like when i'm when
yeah when we have these podcasts
i'm always on the left side okay
you think that they hear this yeah no
but that's because you're a dude like i
see you
and i think you're a perfectly fine
looking guy and but no one thinks that
tr
trust me you know people know i'm a
perfectly good looking guy
no one thinks that but you know hey you
guys know you guys are good-looking guys
too right like
the first time i saw jack i was i was
like there's something off about him and
it was definitely the symmetry of your
face exactly man
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying but no your face is perfect
you should leave that in there seriously
because i'll leave in the asymmetrical
face i'm not gonna leave the number
numero uno though
it's not that big of a deal it is not no
you know you're overweight you don't
understand everything okay how about if
you leave it in
you could have people comment about it
no one
will ever bring that up no every flaw
jack said
i also have really yeah i think
literally everything you said is like
every month
man your arms aren't even i'm pale like
way paler than you i'm hairier than you
no you're not
just because i trim i'm way hairier than
you trim your arms
very rarely but i do i have never done
that well there we go this
podcast every single flaw you said i've
i've had about myself
i don't know man no i don't know but you
know what i can't grow a beard
you both can it doesn't matter i'd
rather not have a beard to be on oh i'd
rather have a beard
really yeah i think it's so cool i've
always wanted to go be i can't do it you
know what dude this is
ridiculous okay so when i was a kid me
and my family yeah we went on a trip to
seattle and there was a grooming place
in seattle where you can buy mustache
trimmers and ever since i was a kid i
just wanted a huge mustache right
enough about that i wanted a massive
mustache ever since i was a kid we go to
this beard groomer place i'm like a
freshman in high school and i'm thinking
i'm gonna buy a mustache trimmer because
i'm starting to grow hair elsewhere
it might come in eight years later
this is what i get after like months of
growing it out
this i literally like i grew hair
everywhere else
wow except these two inches on my
body it's absolutely ridiculous gosh
you should leave that in there seriously
yeah that's
cool all i'm saying is that is the only
way you're gonna be able to get over
this and this is like the first
head start you just do it and actually
i'm
and how you build a brand the more
vulnerable you can be more related
this is your chance yeah you have one
chance to put yourself consider
super uncomfortable but guys but guys
well i also
exaggerated it right because for comedic
effect like i'm not an ape
you know like i said that like as a joke
yeah i'm not that hairy
and i'm but but don't worry guys like
it's not that big of a deal guys like
all right can we move on what's that no
i'm gonna say the only way to move on is
just to embrace
it why don't you guys send yourself
securities i just did mine
mine was height and i'm i wish i could
grow a beard and i can't grow a beer
really yeah because i feel like i
i look too childlike without a beard
that's that's so lame
that's that same criticism about me i
always have a beard just because i think
the same about myself okay
i feel like i look like a child without
a beard but you guys are lucky you don't
want to look old
we are like the same person like the
same insecurities i'm 12.
even though i'm andre what about what
about yours
yeah so we're fine so we don't we all
did it if you now
are the only one who blur out yours
let us know in the comments down below
what your insecurities are yeah
just here's let's let's let's set this
as a as a goal okay
everyone put in your worst do your worst
and you know what if you do the darker
it is the better if you do that i will
respond within the first few days of
commenting a hundred percent and i will
tell everybody
you are great you know don't worry about
a thing all right
and that that'll be that there we go
just just this is a self-help podcast
now
it's it went in a different direction i
think that's a good way to wrap it up
though
it's a very light-hearted way yeah cool
so
thank you guys so much for watching and
thank you for coming on like that was
honestly thanks
for having me yeah it was nice meeting
you as well honestly we didn't introduce
ourselves
yeah i'm jack yeah i'm andre nice to
meet you josh graham
graham i'm smash the like button
well thank you so much for coming on
thank you for having me
so guys make sure to subscribe we'll
link your information down below in the
description
i will find everyone push me over a
million yeah exactly we're gonna get you
to a million today
thank you uh add us on instagram two
free stocks from weeble down below in
the description
mentorship group we got that running
right now so if you want to talk
uh jack and i live twice a week one like
it's not one-on-one but it may as well
be
yeah but so if you want to join that
link down below in the description thank
you so much and
until next time until next time
also um let's get a better introduction
of andre
yeah just because because i don't even
think we mentioned the youtube channel
in the beginning we just talked about uh
the card stuff
you're right okay uh so let me do it
cool
and yeah we're good cool yeah
that was good that was a good mix of fun
all right andre you're gonna introduce
us it's the 22nd
ever episode we have made seven thousand
three three three seven thousand three
hundred dollars welcome to the 22nd
episode
they have so far made seven thousand two
thousand
three hundred thirty welcome to the
22nd ever episode